now here at home a rally in downtown las
vegas is happening in honor of those in
afghanistan madison kimbrough is live
with the details as things are just
getting underway there madison
yes dozens of people are gathered here
in downtown las vegas i'm going to step
out of the way so you can see this event
just started and they're showing their
support for loved ones back home in
afghanistan this event which like i said
just started will last about an hour
with the afghan community in las vegas
making signs and making their voices
heard many of which have family that are
dealing with a tragedy right now
overseas the goal of this rally is to
extend the evacuation past the deadline
of august 31st to allow more refugees to
come to the u.s as you can see it is a
pretty good turnout with this just
having started we expect to see more
people as they are walking by with signs
we see signs that say stand with
afghanistan also what do we want save
afghanistan lives the leader of this
ceremony we talked to briefly we plan to
talk to him a little bit more in the six
o'clock just about what this means to
him as he says his family is from
afghanistan he has many family members
there and what's going on now is
breaking his heart so he wants to make
sure the las vegas community can really
come together and show their support
again we plan to talk to a lot of people
coming up in the six o'clock hour so
we'll have that interview for you but
this is going on for about an hour now
and it should last until six o'clock we
will bring you the very latest details
as this continues reporting live from
downtown las vegas madison kimbrough 8
news now